and I'm really obsessed with these types
of
opportunities uh
because it's easy to get press like you
can see the headlines now Idiot creates
water brand for dogs I can see it
[Laughter]
now yeah great headline formerly
respected individual Greg Eisenberg yeah
disgraces himself with good
one
[Music]
yeah um all right we're live Sean what
do we got what's up uh Greg is here
friend of the house one of the original
one of the original Friends of the house
I you you said something on an earlier
pod that has always stuck with me you
were talking about I think names you had
a you had your iPhone out and you were
on the notes app and you go I just got
Banger names for for businesses that
don't have a business yet with them and
you were just spitting off names and one
of the formats was um anything with the
word Bueno at the end and I can't tell
you how many times I've used this when
somebody's asking me about a name and
they're like yeah we do um we do medical
imaging scans I'm like scan Bueno and
they're like what and they never pick it
but godamn if it doesn't break the ice
uh Greg welcome and do you still have
that notes that note with all those
names I've got all the names I've also
got I don't know 150 startup ideas in a
notes file but before I started I got to
get something off my chest I gotta be
real with you all right what we got
producer Ari you stole my producer did
we we don't know about this fil me in
yes so all of a sudden you guys send me
a text and you go what do you think
about Ari as a producer I see you work
with him with her and I go she's amazing
she's the best you
know there's nothing wrong nothing wrong
about her and then all of a sudden I'm
getting a text from AR being like dude
thank you so much thank you so much I've
just got the craziest job at my first
million if I ever call you for a
reference check just know it's Mr Steal
Your Girl coming coming at you right
there I thought she worked on it in the
past I thought I thought that was that's
what that's what I thought too I thought
there was an end date it's okay is it uh
it happened it happened is it okay it's
not
okay well uh sorry and thank
you okay moving on from that one
um Greg you uh people should know what
you do you have late checkout which is
badass you have one of the best websites
um of any like I don't know company you
make really amazing landing pages uh so
you have late checkout which is
combination Studio agency how do you
describe it holding company building
businesses that have audiences and
communities a part of them and you are
kind of becoming this like Greg the
community guy I feel like that was like
a phase of your life is that still the
phase we're in are we are we is this a
making fetch a thing or is it did it
stick did the Greg the community guy
happen or what what's going on with that
I think so man I think so um I feel like
if other people are calling you that
it's it's a thing if you start calling
yourself the community guy uh and you're
just you know so yeah it's it's
definitely working I feel like that's a
mistake I've made many times trying to
call myself the guy even actually uh
today I was thinking about I was
thinking about Gary ve I was thinking
about one of my favorite YouTubers Cody
Co and I was like why am I not sha P
what what what is Puri doing for me I I
gotta drop the rest of the last name I
just need to be Shawn P and I really
wrote a note to myself I said go all in
on Sha PE and that's
stupid no Workshop it itself you've got
a weird enough first name s h a a an I
think you're good you're good the only
reason why Sam is saying that yeah
jealous he that he's well no you know
Sam he's he wants to be Sam P he wants
to be Sam P come on no man I'm happy I I
I I've got a two syllable first and last
name I'm good I don't need a nickname
when when it's that short you're good um
Sean
Bueno dude Greg late checkout. Studio I
hate your website you're doing this it's
such a designer website I can't click
anything I got to like scroll around a
map in order to find what you do what's
going on man yeah I think listen there's
two ways to create a website one is to
be conversion conversion Centric right
like convert as many people as possible
uh the other way is you're building a
brand and this is
unlike any other website on the internet
I think so we you you'd be surprised how
many million doll deals we've been able
to close cuz people like our website
you've done something that um I think a
lot of people were trying to do but
you've done it well so we've let's talk
about this kind of personal hold co uh
you because you went the Venture path
when I met you you were raising money
from all the big name VCS you were
building a social network like we were
we were both playing that like it's not
even a lottery ticket game the analogy I
give is somebody handed us a bottle or
we picked up a bottle and started
running around trying to catch lightning
and um and that was our like stated game
plan was like ah yes I shall create the
next hit social network now on demand
which is not how any of them got really
built in the first place um so you
played the VC game you have backed off
of it give us your kind of two second
philosophy on how your mindset changed
going from Silicon Valley venture path
to what you do now there was a group of
us now in our 30s who watch The Social
Network that movie and we all thought
that we could become Mark Zuckerberg if
we're being honest with ourselves I mean
I would I would have been happy with a
winkl Voss too but like Yeah I wanted to
be Zuck yes we saw that movie it jazzed
us up there was a whole generation of us
who moved to Silicon Valley to go and
raise a bunch of money to build social
apps
and you know we
tried we tried and the truth is it's
it's you know I remember meeting one of
the world's uh best investors and he he
once told me that
a third of our deals fail a third of our
deals we get our money back and a third
of our deals we make 1X to Google
times so that got me thinking that what
he's basically saying is that the best
Founders in the world because he's only
backing the best Founders twoth thirds
of them basically the founders and their
teams don't see any money from
Acquisitions that means a third of
companies are basically seeing any
profit it's just so difficult to win in
that game and yeah so that's why I've
been focusing more on profitable cash
filling
businesses our software is the worst
have you heard of HubSpot see most crms
are a cobble together mess but HubSpot
is easy to adopt and actually looks
gorgeous I think I love our new CRM our
software is the best HubSpot grow better
are you making more money now doing the
cash flow Thing versus when you sold
your company AB yes absolutely yeah do
you like your life better yeah and do
you do you have a goal like a like cash
flow goal you're like okay my goal is to
get to 10 million in cash flow or
whatever like is that how you're
thinking about is that the game that
you're currently playing no the game I'm
playing is I'm playing for style points
[Laughter]
baby what does that even mean is there
is there anything else to say no that
explains everything next question
what is what's the style point we were
talking about when Sam was at working at
HubSpot he was like I'm an artist baby I
got create I think that's what Greg's
talking about when he talks about style
points uh the other part of style points
is like the lifestyle so in silan Valley
this idea of a lifestyle lifestyle
business is like a um it's a backhanded
compliment so it's it's a way for people
in Silicon Valley to Pat you on the head
and be like that's cute that's a cute
business um like good for you good you
that's swell um but like to me I'm like
that's crazy like the point point of
these business is to give myself and my
team awesome Lifestyles like what else
are you what are you trying to do if not
that I don't I don't even understand and
so I feel like one of the kind of
arbitrages right now is in especially if
you're from the tech industry is the
whole tech industry is so brainwashed
that it's all about creating
multibillion dollar companies that um a
lot of people who would actually be
super happy if they created a lifestyle
business that gave gave them $25 million
a year of cash flow um won't ever go
that path because it's seen as kind of
this like lesser lesser thing to do it
we all have friends who do that you know
I I tease or we we teased them on air
Andrew Wilkinson for doing for doing
that um but you know what was funny is
do you guys see uh chamath from Allin he
uh so chth for the listener I I I I
would assume he's a billionaire if he's
not a billionaire many many hundreds of
millions very very very wealthy uh the
other day he announced that he was
starting a paid newsletter and I think
it was $100 a year um and what's funny
is there's two things that I found to be
true is I've talked to someone who says
they don't want to be public and then
they get on Twitter or they get on
YouTube or something and they taste that
do that dopamine and they go oh this is
nice I'm gonna I'm gonna do this again
and they love the even though like you
know the people who are like oh I can't
do it I don't want to do I don't want to
be public ey they get the public eye and
they love it the second thing I've
noticed is even people who have big
compan that are maybe Venture back
companies and there's a very likely
outcome where they're wildly wealthy
even making $50,000 $100,000 a month
that can be addicting I wonder what what
Chamas plays with that but he has a he
has a paid newsletter now well even
worse he's like uh yeah and we're we're
going to have it be paid and so that's
really cool because the revenue from
that um it makes this whole thing
sustainable like we can we can use it to
hire more researchers and do better
research it's like hey why don't you
take the 0.1% interest on your uh
savings account that you have in with
with JP Morgan right now and use that to
pay for seven researchers it's fine
actually like it it's crazy to me that
like what you know people say like
what's the point of money if you
don't say you like what's the point
of being a billionaire if you're
gonna do a paid newsletter like what is
what is happening right now the point is
it's addicting and so my point being is
where a lot of people who like would
make fun of Lifestyle businesses once I
mean and I was that person I was like I
want to go big and then I start tasting
like a monthly monthly income that's
good I'm like oh this is awesome I I was
texting Andrew Wilkinson making fun of
him too cuz he was doing a paid Twitter
subscriber thing and I was like dog you
have a foundation you're talking you're
signing the giving pledge um like what
do you care about this like 10K a month
um you know subscriber Revenue that you
now have to go tap dance for to like
perform and give them their
value but it hits for him like there's
something to it uh that for for that
that's like giving him that value um I
was I couldn't believe it to the point
where I told him I was like the only
explanation for this that makes any
sense to me is you're using the Twitter
paid features so that Elon is like see
this guy's doing it and he puts you he
starts retweeting you uh because you're
promoting his thing that he's trying to
make work and then you end up becoming
friends with Elon Musk I said that's the
only reasonable explanation for this and
he denied it he Didi I I actually get
Andrew doing his his premium X thing a
little bit more because like he's having
interaction with his fans but the
chamama thing around like putting up
gated content makes absolutely no sense
did you have Greg did you have any other
ideas or uh Niche businesses you wanted
to get off your chest let's just rapid
fire all right give us give us one this
one's a is a happy idea so it's a crazy
one but a happy one it's listen to me
now athletic greens for dogs
okay okay keep going go on ag1 athletic
greens came out of nowhere started
sponsoring all these podcasts
YouTubers uh and I don't know if they're
what do you think their revenue is Sam
600 million 500 million I think they
kill it but I'll do the homie move and
say 100 million yeah okay more than 100
million they're they're really really
crushing it using that model
now dogs are similar to humans in the
sense that they drink water they drink
tap water and the question is what if
dogs drank something that was better
from them better for them than plain old
water okay so uh here's the Playbook you
find the Andrew huberman for dogs you
sponsor every Top Dog Creator in animals
lovered podcast you give packets to to
restaurants and and bowls that say this
brand for their dogs and then you profit
the name we call it the name we call it
good water and our slogan we do good
dogs deserve good
water now we have to figure out what we
can put in the water so that it
actually is better than water
itself
but this is a good example of how do you
create a category of one how do you
build something where you're building
something where no one else is playing
and I'm really obsessed with these types
of
opportunities uh
because it's easy to get press like you
can see the headlines now Idiot creates
water brand for dogs I can see it
[Laughter]
now gr headline formerly respected
individual GRE
yeah disgraces himself with good
water Sean P says it's really better
than water I swear is Gatorade for dogs
the next great thing yeah
like this is some stupid Greg we're
good waterb bad idea this it sounds like
something uh Misfits or what's that
called what's that what's that company
called that Mischief I got tell you when
Craig Clemens came on the Pod one time
many years ago and he was like guys uh
we were like what ideas you got he's
like VR for dogs and this is the guy
who's made like 10 hit products so he's
not like some one hit wonder he's got 10
he's had 10 great ideas and on our pod
he comes on and says VR for dogs and
both me and you were like we didn't know
him that well to be like roast him like
we just did Greg but we were like tell
us more um but you know we were not in
on it but then I swear every time I
leave the cuz he was like look he's like
I would pay any if my dog could be
entertained when they're alone like or
just you know I just don't want them to
be bored and now I swear every time I
leave the house and my dog sitting there
just going to stare at a wall and I'm
like bet your ass I'd strap on some a
pair of pair of uh you know Oculus for
dog goggles if if it actually kept my
dog entertained so I think he was right
on right in in
spirit gr I want to talk to you about
some of these ideas because you the
first one you talk about Ryan holiday
who's been on the pod is my buddy I'm a
huge fan of and you seem like you're in
a spicy mood first I'm always in a spicy
mood uh I just want to put that out
there um for the the record is said for
the record the record is said okay uh
yeah let's talk about the first idea so
Ryan holiday uh incredible incredible
guy like he's built such a huge brand
around
stoicism
stoicism was basically the dead unless
you know you were studying philosophy at
Columbia uh these people like senica
Aristotle um maybe You' see quotes here
and there but it was basically dead and
what he did is he introduced
stoicism the Great Name by the way daily
stoic to millions of genz and
Millennials um so I think that there's
an opportunity to do exactly what Ryan
holl did uh but in the Fable space so do
you remember remember asop asop fables
no what is
that okay so asop uh is just one of one
of the most well-known uh
storytellers uh of all time of humanity
he of humanity he did like the tortoise
and the
hair uh or the the wolf and sheep's
clothing so it's basically these little
stories that use animals to
to tell you know the moral of the
story
and it's got a lot of great stuff in
there just like uh senica had a lot of
great stuff in there so um I think that
if you you know got the handle the daily
fabler uh and you started telling these
incredible stories and quotes from
it uh you can build an audience really
quickly through that um and similar to
how Ryan
holiday um you know Ryan holiday for
those who don't know monetized via
courses but he also monetized via his
book but he also my favorite part of how
he monetizes is he literally
sells it's a coin he calls it a
medallion uh so he's got this Medallion
called momento Mory hey I have one okay
why did you get one because he gave it
to me and I thought it was awesome but I
I do think it's cool I I carried it
around with me for years I I thought it
was cool I I forget what do moment it
means uh like you're going to die or
like live the day or something like that
yeah basically means uh like Seize the
Day right like you're going to die and
if you know you're going to die and
you're and you're facing mortality then
it's Greek for YOLO yeah it's Greek for
YOLO momento Mori is Greek for YOLO so
that's a and people pay $30 for this and
I'm sure that he's making millions of
dollars selling
coins to his audiences via Twitter Tik
Tok and Instagram and
YouTube it's this same model but for
fables he told us this on the Pod and it
blew my mind he came on and he was like
yeah um I sell this coin it's like you
know cost me whatever I don't know what
it was but like you know let's call it a
dollar just be generous assume this coin
costs a dollar he partnered with this
mint in the US they mint the coin he
sends it and he's like yeah you know
I've sold shirts before I think he
worked at American Apparel he was like
the head of marketing American Apparel
he's like you know apparel sucks merch
sucks shirts t-shirts suck because
there's so many sizes and colors and
whatever he's like there's one skew it's
one coin there's no return I sell it in
a two pack I sell it in a two pack it
ships in an envelope because it's the
lightest weight thing so like shipping
is easy making it is easy selling it is
easy because it's a it's a uh you know
it's a single skew product he's like it
was the low headache way to have a merch
store for stoicism and I was like this
guy's genius and I I remember I don't
know if he told us or I was doing some
math when I was thinking about
I'm pretty sure he's made over $20
million just selling this coin I think
on the Pod he said he sold tens of
thousands of coins yeah and then if you
do the math it's like whatever I think
that you know 25 $20 a coin or something
like that yeah I mean he told us and and
and he's killing it um but what did you
say here you said uh it's harder to be
senica than it is sahill Bloom it's
harder to be Aristotle than Alex
Heros yeah so there's a bunch of
Tailwinds with this business so first of
all creating content is way more
difficult
than curating content and Distilling
content and I want people to to know
that because there's a ton of businesses
that you can create where you don't need
to come up with any original ideas you
can just curate Amazing Ideas that other
people will have hey you're talking to
two of the guys that did that the the
hustle did that milro did that exactly
it's way easier to get your own podcast
producer that to steal your podcast
producer you know what I'm
saying Al also my newsletter the five
tweet Tuesday it's the highest rated
newsletter I've ever made it's high open
rate get the most feedback on it and
it's also the easiest thing because I'm
just curating five of the most
interesting tweets versus try to create
my own original blog post every Tuesday
so yeah so yeah it is easier to be sah
Bloom than Sedaka and it is easier to be
Alex Orosi than uh Aristotle because
they could just take other people's
Concepts and curate it so this this
daily fable
idea has that Tailwind with it and it's
got a few more Tailwinds to it one is
that another one is that
uh gen Z basically doesn't believe in
God almost
50% of gen Z is either una affiliated
with any religion or does not believe in
God but they seek
out uh it's just human nature to seek
out uh some greater meaning and purpose
in life so that's why they're filling
their time with daily stoic and could
fill their time with you know something
like the daily Fable and this is what I
call like the unbundling of religion
what is this uh Pink pinks thing pinks
so pinks uh someone I work with uh
partner of mine Jordan he you know he's
rolling around Austin and he sees this
pink truck outside a house and outside
this pink truck is these men you know
with
mustaches and
mullets uh with these pink shirts tucked
in you know he's thinking to himself is
this a porno
shoot like what is the what is going on
over
here and then he sees this logo pinks
pinks window
cleaning and he he finds out that it's a
uh it's a new uh Window Cleaning Service
based in
Austin and it's actually a franchise
business and if you go to their website
thinks windows.com
uh they they basically you know they've
got this boring business window washing
and they they they jazzed it up and they
they even have like a merch store where
they've apparently sold thousands and
thousands of hats oh my god look I was
at dinner the other night and barop is
wearing this hat and look at it I go I
think I even said I go what's this uh
there something cool what is this I I
know you're doing something cool what is
this because he's part one of these guys
that like he knows the Indie bands he
knows the cool restaurant to eat at he
knows cool and um and so he's like
cuz I'm like why why else would he be
wearing a window washing hat this makes
no sense and he's like ah it's this
brand called pinks they're really cool
I'm like they're cool window washing how
do you even know like compared to what
like I couldn't tell you one window
washing brand let alone the coolest one
and he's like yeah I'm like so you
bought the Hat he's like I bought the
Hat style points baby and that was the
that was the end of that story I went
back home and I ordered a Pink's hat
because I was like if it's cool then I
will be the follower and and try to do
it too so this is a part of a bigger
Trend which is that I think this is kind
of like the uh Dollar Shave Club
ification of boring
businesses so I think a a lot of people
younger people are going to be buying
some of these businesses you know
Boomers are retiring you know the story
there but I think what they're going to
do is they're gon to make it feel like a
an indie band you know you remember the
dollar shaped Club video right it was
funny yeah it it took something boring
razor shaving
Gillette and made it like super cool and
fun and and that's what Pink's is is
doing that's actually super smart cuz
that actually kicked off like a huge
wave of DDC Brands like Sam always jokes
Sam what's your joke about DDC Brands
how do how do you know a DDC brand when
you see one well because they like uh
it's always lowercase it's the same uh
it's the same font it's uh they always
use Millennial pink yeah exactly and so
you so it kicked Dollar Shave Club
kicked off this wave of DDC brands from
Casper away luggage and then you know
like just one after another and you know
there's hundreds of them at this point
um which was basically like take boring
category uh do best-in-class like kind
of branding around it put put a ton
of money into the set or or creative
effort into The Branding and then sell
that kind of commodity product online
and what you're saying is people are now
going to do that for these these uh
sweaty startup businesses so instead of
doing the boring like if you go look at
self storage or U-Haul like these are
some of the worst looking Brands you'll
ever see and maybe instead of the soft
the the lowercase you know block letter
font with the soft P you know the the
that that Millennial pink maybe it's
this like vintage retro Indie band uh
look that's going to become the like the
go-to thing for window washing trash
Hall removal um you know HVAC all this
stuff that is that what you're saying
because I think that's actually kind of
brilliant yeah I'm going to call my shot
here and say that pinks is the beginning
of this whole new generation over the
next 5 to 10 years you're going to see
pinks for x uh you're going to see pinks
for uh Lawn Care Pest Control Car Wash
catering pet
grooming uh snow removal and I think
it'll it doesn't necessarily need to be
like
Nostalgia plus design but it could also
be just it's just in different
interesting and unexpected so the guy it
looks like the brand behind pink is
called resi Brands it looks like they
own three or four things they own one
called garage up which is like making a
garage look cool and clean then there's
pinks then there's that one painter and
then if you Google it you can find the
guy who owns it is this guy named stepen
Montgomery and he's young he's young
with like sleeve tattoos he looks maybe
30 he looks like a kid uh it's pretty
fascinating uh this is a really
interesting find do you know what their
revenue is for Ry Brands is it is it
going well yeah so first of all he is
young I think he graduated college like
five or six years ago um resi brand
started recently and within the last
couple years and their painting brand
that one painter is the fastest growing
Painting Company in the United States so
this is a model that's starting to work
and if I'm like
a PE fund like this is what I'm doing
I'm basically acquiring boring
businesses I'm hiring an agent see like
laid checkout and I'm I'm building
Brands not boring
businesses he's like I'm joining Hampton
then I check out find some Talent on
Shephard exactly bada bing bada boom I'm
there we uh I be I was I was uh I used
to be close with Brian the guy who
started 800 got
junk and he was telling me all about
franchises and so 1800 got Junk was its
own thing he started it with just one
trunk
uh or one uh one truck and grew it and I
think now he owns 100% of it it does
like2 or $300 million in Revenue really
valuable business but he was telling me
that they took off when they did
franchises franchises that's when they
really started kicking ass but dealing
and working with franchise owners he
said or I don't know if he said it or a
COO Cameron he was like it's very very
very hard uh and I think it's sort of
like the agency business where you're
like oh looks so simple you just do this
you do that but doing it every single
day I think is a huge challenge it's
almost like working in the restaurant
industry you know your server won't show
up because they're hung over or you got
to deal with fights every once in a
while I think it's I think it has a
similar uh a similar type of headache
you know what I mean it's probably hard
to manage and and yeah I want to be
clear on this pinks is actually now it
started as one location in Austin and
now they're you could franchise your own
pinks like if you want to bring one to
New York or wherever uh so they
basically
charge uh 2% marketing fee a 7% royalty
fee and a franchise fee of at least
$449,000 I think it's 49,000 to
100,000 uh and they actually share some
of their revenue numbers so for their
one of their Austin locations they've
got seven employees they're doing 7
142,000 in revenue and they're making
36% profit on that to
$268,000 so it's a pretty good business
um and yeah you're right that it's a
pain to to manage some of those
employees but uh there's something here
although I got to say the disclaimer uh
we we don't know if this is a great
business is not advice and also uh you
know franchise uh like headquarters tend
to share the numbers of like the best
performing thing not like you know the
average or the median um because we
talked about a business that has a
franchise I was like oh this is a cool
idea I think this thing you know just
looking at the traffic it look like it
might have you know here a guess at one
much it was making and then their
franchise calendar got booked out like
the meetings got booked out for like
four months after the Pod came out so uh
definitely uh can't say I I personally
don't endorse this maybe Greg uh is but
I personally do not this is not my first
million sponsored okay so what I was
gonna say on pinks is I went I didn't
know anything about franchises until
like any internet entrepreneur I didn't
going down the Pink's rabbit hole
and I I didn't realize that franchises
for sure are regulated by a franchise
board so that that's also just an
interesting thing to know about if you
want to do a franchise you have to go to
these portals you have to apply there's
only certain
uh information that they can disclose so
I found that quite interesting and then
the other thing interesting thing um
that got me thinking about pinks and
franchises is I started thinking about
like what is franchise model what does
that look like for the internet so what
is a franchise a franchise is basically
uh a set of it's a business model and a
box and a brand and a box and support in
a box for an
entrepreneur how could we bring that or
is there an opportunity to bring that to
the internet I had the same thought when
you were talking earlier about your
agency about how scaling agencies is
hard
and maybe I don't know why but
franchising was on my mind and I was
like I wonder why like if I was a like
if I'm me and I have a big audience I
have a large ability to create a brand
and get customers the painful part is
the operations what most people do is
they partner with somebody they run the
operations but they're going to run into
the scaling headaches and bottlenecks
along the way and I was like What if I
franchised it meaning I could you could
spin up you could become one of my
operators or a partner in the business
I'm going to hand you customers
like automatically you don't have to
know how to do internet marketing you
don't have to build your own brand you
just have to fulfill the demand that I
generate and we kind of like let's just
say it was uh I don't know design or web
development or something I don't know I
don't know what what category makes
sense but like you could just have a
three person team that's going to bang
out high quality work and do as much
work as you're able to generate but like
we don't have to create a 100 person
agency headquarters that's going to like
have managers man managers and ensure
the quality of work and then have to
like increase prices because of we all
these layers of management like maybe
there's another way maybe there's a way
to do it I don't know if that fully
makes sense but it was a thought that
came to mind earlier when you were
talking about scaling Ines yeah maybe
maybe what we're saying is the next
generation of Creator Le agencies
actually look more like franchises than
they do what they are now right because
nor normally a franchise the reason you
franchise is because you can't
geographically expand so like why does
chipot why did chipot
initially franchise out is because this
concept works we can physically only
launch so many locations ourselves with
the capital we have and the like time we
have we can't be in Alabama right now
but there should be some chipotes in
Alabama so they find a franchisee there
with the internet you don't have the
geography problem so that's why I think
most internet companies never franchise
however I do think that for things that
are like service like um you know a
service is rendered I think that's kind
of similar in that you run into
servicing bottle
where I disagree with you on the
geography thing is I think it's it's not
that we don't have a geography problem
on on the Internet it's just that
geography is defined differently
geography is defined in the real world
like you know at the corner of 25th and
5th Avenue versus on the internet like
you have an audience you have people
coming into your store every day it's
just a different definition of geography
so I think that if someone could figure
out and this is for the audience if
someone could figure out and US honestly
if we can figure out how we could take
the benefits of uh a franchise model and
figure out how we can uh you know the
reason okay if you go to Chipotle in New
York City or you go to Chipotle in San
Francisco the burrito tastes the same
the problem with the Creator like going
back to Crea lead agencies is the the
the the type of uh product is very
different as those businesses are
scaling uh unless the operators are you
know have been doing this for many years
so I think there's something here
there's another version of this that is
kind of on the internet uh are you guys
familiar with EOS no okay so uh EOS is
basically a operating system for an
entrepreneur so basically we've all felt
it you're a CEO you're running your
business and you're making it up as you
go so it's not not just like what's that
analogy like oh we're building the plane
as we're flying it it's like no we're
literally like trying to figure out what
is a like what what shape will fly while
we're flying it and so um you're making
up how to run your company but you don't
need to there are best practices for how
to run a company that will apply to like
you know 80 90% of businesses and so
what EOS did was this guy wrote this
book I don't know the full backstory but
this guy wrote a book called traction
and in traction he's talking about how
to run a like how he runs his business
it's like oh we come up with our annual
plan and we use this scorecard here's a
scorecard template you can go download
that for free and like it's basically
it's like here's a a blueprint a model
for how to run your company I've never
used it I used it I know a lot of people
use it and it's like you have rocks and
like each person's responsible for three
rocks and it's like this whole like
strategic thing okay's some somewhat
similar uh to it which is like a goal
setting system um so e is actually like
kind of a monstrous business from what I
understand and the way they work is kind
of through this franchise model so what
they do is they have these implementers
so EOS basically takes the lead and then
they're like cool you're interested in
implementing EOS and it's it's really
expensive it's like like Sam when you
did it what' you do it for Hampton or
for hustle for the hustle I just read
the book and then I just implemented it
and I showed people how to do it I
couldn't afford to do the normal thing
but it's many tens of thousands of
dollars for like a two work like 25 or
50k or something like that so it's a
quite expensive uh for most people to
like swallow that um or it's just like I
don't know you have to have a lot of
conviction that that's going to really
help you you in order to pay this but
these there are a bunch of people out
there that are just simply EOS
implementers they're not they're not
like they're not part of the company but
they are basically like these kind of
freelance people that will do this I
don't know the exact structure so I'm
talking a little little you know off the
off the top here so so I might get some
things wrong here from what I understand
you have traction which is the book that
generates a lot of leads of people who
are interested in implementing this they
go to the website they say great I want
to do this they book a call and then
they either you sort of like you know
buy the system or the system with the
implementation fee or whatever and then
they're paying a person who's like kind
of their coach to help them implement
this system and then whatever and I
actually know a bunch of people that
have done this I'm not you what I've
noticed is it's kind of more beginning
entrepreneurs it's like the best
operators I know typically weren't the
ones who were telling me they used EOS
but that's just an observation I don't I
don't know if that's if that's fair or
not but it is quite heavy it's like a
lot it's like a fullon system it's like
a full revamp of how you what meetings
do you run every week and how you do
them and all this stuff I've had this
craving to do a lightweight version of
EOS cuz I have a system that works for
me I've used it for like 15 years I've
like fine-tuned it along the way and I'm
like and every time I meet an
entrepreneur and they have some
bottleneck they're hitting I'm like okay
well let's Trace down to the root cause
of this like what's getting you into
this pickle and usually it's that
there's something in their process
that's causing them to run into this
issue and if you fix the process you'll
fix the issue um and I don't know if
it's a perfect process but like it's
lightweight which I think is more for
someone like me like I'm not going to go
hire EOS and pay these guys you know
$30,000 and spend six months revamping
my company probably like I don't really
want to do that but if there was a
lightweight version I would do it and I
think the the only thing that stops me
from implementing that is I don't want
to have a giant consulting company that
I'm running to do that uh whereas if
there was this franchise model and
people could basically come train like
come to my workshop seminar and do like
a 4-we certification process to learn
exactly how to do it and then they could
go do it on their own and make their own
money doing it that would be fun I I
would do something like that I think
that's how EOS works yeah and and I
wouldn't be surprised if that thing
makes like $30 million a year and like
$15 million a year in profit um I the
people who are into it they're obsessed
with it um Greg what's this uh what's
this this what's it called playing field
I don't know how you found that that's
fascinating because I go to the website
and you can't even sign up so Nathan
Barry from convert kit told me about
this one um
basically it's Tom Brady's manager uh
he's got this newsletter it's the most
expensive newsletter in the world you
had my attention and now you have my
interest so uh his company is called
playing field and his newsletter is
called the brief um it's invitation only
I think there's a a maximum of about a
thousand sub subscribers in order to get
on the list you actually have to be an
NFL owner or you have to be just like a
really really badass top
player um and this is like a part of a
bigger Trend uh which I think is like
luxury
newsletters so or or even a bigger macro
Chen which is you know there's all these
uh Mega Ultra
Luxury uh Rich experiences popping up
for the top 1% be it like so house or
private Disney tours or am that hotel
that charges like 5K a month 5K 5K a
night k a night 5K a night and you're
seeing that in the market like reflected
like Hermes has a bigger market cap than
Nike you know so uh I think the same
thing is happening with newsletters and
I think there's an opportunity to uh
basically
do uh to what everyone is trying not to
do what everyone is trying to do is
build a newsletter to get to the hustle
level or to get to milk Road level but
what if you tried to do the complete
opposite what if you created a
newsletter for the top 1% that was very
very Niche focused um and you just
treated it like a nightclub my favorite
my favorite quote is uh Andy Warhol I
think he said Studio 54 is a
dictatorship at the door but a democracy
on the dance
floor and I think there's a way to bring
that student
54 mentality to building luxury
newsletters in a bunch of different
spaces how much do you think they charge
for
this I mean we got to buy an NFL team to
find
out so how much is how much in the Jets
CA dude this this idea style points I
mean
wow this incredible what a what a
hilarious and incredible idea that
actually makes sense when you think
about it there was a guy it was a big
article in some uh some like you know
Forbes or whatever and it was about this
guy and he's got this like you know that
Rya was like the dating app for like hot
celebrities or whatever this guy created
like the the r the Rya of like
experiences or something oh I saw this
is the guy who partner with Justin
timberlink mirria I guess
as this guy's specialty is getting like
super VIP experiences that like one of a
kind of experiences that you can't um
you can't like you can't buy or you
can't find anywhere else yeah basically
Andrew wi Andrew Wilkinson told me about
it if I remember correctly Andrew
Wilkinson either went to the Grammys or
the Oscars one of those like things he
sent me this picture of him in a tuxedo
at on the red carpet and I was like what
the hell and he goes yeah I was part of
this community or this service called I
I forget what it was called but the guy
started with Justin timberlink or
something like that went through YC and
it's about getting experiences that you
can't normally get but you can buy your
way into if you know the right people
right right okay I'm going to read you
some of the quotes from this uh this
thing so here here's what it says it
goes um you know somebody will call him
and they'll say um like he could
basically get you treated like you were
an American Diplomat and like you needed
to be like handled uh like he could do
that for you and so he's like oh um you
know you need this epic party in Mexico
with private CHF just you just tell me
what you need you don't have to worry
about the rest it's going to happen and
so what he'll do is he'll create like
okay um you're not just going to the
Beyonce concert you're going to get to
go into the dressing room and you're
going to get to hang out afterwards or
she's going to call your kid on stage
and get to sing with them like something
that these like one of one style um
style experiences so here's what it says
mirror only accepts ultra high net worth
uh people defined as people worth over
30 million this he says this isn't the
1% it's the
0.003% um you must be willing to spend
an average of 1 million a year on
lifestyle alone so um just on these
experiences you're willing to spend a
million bucks in order to get in um let
me see if it has he's focusing on the
needs of the top 10,000 people in the
world and we're going to do for them
what nobody else can do and so he's like
he's like almost like a fixer like in uh
you know uh the wolf fiction he's like
he's like the wolf he's like the one you
call in when you need you just need that
special something yeah so that's that's
for like physical experiences um but I
think what you're starting to see also
is this trend around uh apps and
software newsletters uh as a status
symbol what's another example of that
Rya was a great example of that um but I
think superhuman is another good example
so superhuman is that email software
that a lot of BCS use and it's kind of
it's like 30 bucks a month or something
it's kind it's kind of a flex that you
you can say sent from super send from
super human it's like Gmail is probably
better than superhuman let's be real um
but having sent from superhuman adds
this like layer of oh I take my um I
take my job really seriously like I'm a
part of the 1% so I think there's an
opportunity for people to not only
create playing field for X but also
super human for x and other software for
X well like um the easiest one of this
on the Internet Is nfts Right nfts were
exactly this so um like just to your
point of Hermes having a higher market
cap than Nike well when you know when
nfts were were out they were basically
luxury art I forgot somebody said this
thing uh you know art is just money you
could hang on your wall I was like oh
that's great uh well you know nfts were
basically money you could hang on your
profile and um that's why you know
people would spend hundreds of thousands
of dollars on an ape or a punk because
it meant something and when these were
happening uh my buddy Vall he told me
he's like oh yeah these are velin Goods
uh and I was like what's a velin good I
never heard of that you guys know what
this is no what's that word I don't even
know what that word means Yeah so
basically a VIN good is something where
the demand increases as the price
increases so uh most Goods they follow
the the traditional Supply demand curve
which is that as a price decreases the
demand will increase for that item ablin
good works the exact opposite way as the
price decreases the demand also
decreases this is why nft projects can
get huge overnight because if the price
runs up it puts that product in more
demand but if the price starts to crash
that nft value is crashing with the
price the demand crashes with the with
the price and so once you understand
that there's a set of luxury goods like
this then um it explains a whole class
like you know the first time I heard
about a Birkin bag I was like oh so it's
got like an elevator inside what's the
deal why is this so expensive why do
people care it's like well they care
because you can't buy it I'm like well
you can't buy it why what do you mean
why don't they sell it they should sell
more of these and they're like no no no
you you have to be you have to earn the
right to buy the Birkin bag and it's
like I had a cousin who flew to Paris to
like go to the store to try to buy a
Birkin bag and I'm like this you made a
out of this and she's like yeah like I'm
I've been working my way up I had to buy
all these other luxury bags just to be
invited to possibly buy a bur holy
dude these bags are uh I'm looking at a
used one on some website it's a quarter
of a million and then there's other used
ones for 30,000 so it's like the cheap
end is $30,000 for these bags I think
it's like 50k if you just buy it from
the story is holy and you know and
so it's it's a status symbol because
even amongst luxury buyers you can't buy
like you can buy all you can have all
the money you want you can walk into
Louis Vuitton you can buy everything you
know what you can't buy a Birkin why
because a Birkin is even elevated above
that and I'm like wow there is no end to
the status game that gets played uh when
it comes to this stuff and it makes you
think like you know remember when the
iPhone came out and that guy made like
the app that cost $1,000 and it was
called the I'm rich app or something
like that it was just it was like a red
light or something would turn on and it
that means you bought the I'm rich app
for $1,000 it did nothing else besides
that and it got so popular Apple then
started to take it took it off the store
because it was like this is not what we
want but the fact that that worked tells
you something about the psychology of
people that they would they would do
that to Signal you know their status man
this is amazing I I've heard that word
but I've never actually seen these bags
this is wild to me um this is this is
this is insane wow all right what do we
want to do now we got to wrap up in a
minute yeah give us one more one more
Greg stripe Atlas for
trademarks
so we recently filed a
trademark uh we bought the domain boring
marketing.com
and it's dope and the business started
scaling and we're like oh we need a
trademark uh here and I don't know if
you guys have filed for trademarks but
the process is insane it's it's a pain
in the butt it's a pain in the butt it's
actually quite expensive and you even
have to finish your work on going on
these like Craigs listy looking uh sites
and it's pretty brutal well let's
explain it what happens you typically
what you do is you hire a lawyer so
that's you know already start off on the
wrong foot then they're like great can't
just file this got to do a search first
you want the light search for 300 bucks
or you want the comprehensive search
which might actually find the thing for
$800 you're like I guess I'll do the
search uh because because if you don't
do the I'm like what if I don't do the
search like well we could file it and
you that'll cost you money but then you
don't know if you get it or not I'm like
cool for like how long like like a year
maybe a year and a half I'm like but
then I I have to operate my company
right like so what happens if I don't
get it like well you might need to
change your company's name like all
right I guess I'll do the search then
they pay then you hire them for the
search and then they're like great now
we can file hey which class do you want
to file in and you're like you're on
USPTO this the Craigslist looking you're
talking about and you're trying to
figure out what the hell's going on and
finally you file it and then nothing
happens and then nothing ever happens
basically like a year later you'll get a
letter you got approv and then you're
like was that even necessary and then
you're like this is this is just a crazy
process overall exactly so and then and
then so it's it's it's very similar to
uh what happened with strip Atlas so for
those of those of people who don't know
what stripe Atlas is it's 500 bucks and
you can basically
uh you know form a legal entity issue
stock to founder is filing an 83b
election which is super painful in the
United States they basically took
something that was really painful and
expensive and made it easy and cheap and
the smartest thing about that for stripe
which is obviously a payments company is
once you've set up all those things when
you they basically send you a stripe
link and stripe makes money when you
sell stuff so you're all ready to go and
it basically onboards you to stripe
which is brilliant there's the same
opportunity to do that for um trademarks
so like the name I would use if I was
doing this would be Mr trademark the
slogan would be something like putting
you out of your
misery
and I think that uh either something
like this gets bought by a stripe so I
think there's an opportunity there but I
actually think that you probably would
would try to hold out for something like
that and allow yourself to on board to
other different services and I think you
can expand this Beyond just trademarks
to patents as well um I have some
thoughts on patents and trademarks like
I don't know if patents and trademarks
are just astrology for
entrepreneurs um but you know because I
I've I've actually I've had a I've you
know I've been at companies where we've
had patents for example stumble upon
which was basically this uh they
acquired my company and I was on the
management team there I find out like
one of the reasons I sold the business
was because I was like these guys have
the patent on like recommendation
engine like which is mostly nonsense
right dude it was like they were like we
have the patent on this this alone is
worth you know $500 a billion dollars
because basically they had the patent on
if you upb something or downb something
and there's a recommendation engine at
the core of it that is their patent AKA
Tik Tok I I I think that's worked that's
worked a couple times though on the
internet uh I believe Reed Hoffman and
Mark Marcus pink Mark or Marcus Pinkus
the guy who started Zinga I think they
had
some I get his name wrong what's his
name we're gonna go yeah Marcus p is
Marcus pink whatever would be such an
outrageous name I don't know he's he's
an outrageous guy uh didn't he own
didn't they own the patent that I
believe if memory serves correct I
believe they owned a p patent on the
algorithm for social media and I think
they sold it to Facebook or maybe even
they gave it for to Facebook and
exchange for shares did you guys not
read that story no I don't know that
story but when we bought the bio brand
back we got these patents with it and
they had a patent for the uh for the
Whiteboard feature meaning like you
could go on someone's profile page I
don't know if you remember this like you
could go on someone's profile page and
doodle like just draw on a like a
Microsoft Paint looking whiteboard there
we had the patent for that and I was
like cool but Facebook has that feat at
the time Facebook had something called
the wall that was the same thing like
they had used to have that feature too
and used to be able to and Myspace had
graffiti and like it was the same
feature and they were like yeah these
don't mean anything and I was like
nothing like is it patent like Ironclad
they're like yeah just like not on the
internet and uh that's been my
experience with I don't know if that's
actually true or not but it seems like
trademarks kind of mean something
because if you don't own your trademark
and somebody does they can basically
tell you you're you you can't keep
operating under that name which is
painful and when you sell a company they
like to for you to have everything
buttoned up like yes I'm Incorporated
I've paid my taxes I have my trademarks
I'm free and clear to be bought um but I
don't think patents do anything on the
internet what I understand well okay so
in 20 yeah so uh Pinkus and Reed Hoffman
they own this patent called the six
degrees patent Facebook I believe bought
it from them for
$700,000 um but uh yeah it it there's an
article called uh who owns Facebook's
most important patent so apparently it
was a thing cool Greg uh so you're going
to come on next time are you gonna have
goodwater decom or no you're a good
you're a doio type of guy well Shan's
fired sh's fired you're well you're what
your agency now it's um there's two Wars
happening right now and that was a hate
crime you just committed calling him AIO
guy all all I know is that just I'm
wearing glasses and you know if that oh
here we go it's uh s. just joined the
chat what what's your uh where do where
do people connect it's a it's a is it
public school or checkout. Studio L
checkout. Studio see I knew you're not a
dotcom type of guy you have late
checkout. substack dcom right uh I like
your newsletter what else uh what else
do you want to pimp you you're you're
always tweeting cool uh you always
Tweet stuff with the first line being
like the future of blank is blank uh
which I dig Greg back in the day wrote a
series of blog posts called like tiny
little life hacks or something what's
the name of that post Greg I this like
10 years ago little life hacks guarantee
Tim forve your life but this is before
like thread boy yeah yeah exactly you
were ahead of your time uh now today
these are you know you see these all the
time but back then these were great and
I actually implemented many of these
little ones that you you did like a
three-part series it was so good that
people called you back for an encore and
second Encore on top of that so go read
that series if you want to love Greg
like if people read that they'll fall in
love with you I guarantee your first one
is dress formal when you go on flights
do you do that it it worked back in the
day it actually worked you know this is
this is years ago yeah what else what
else on that list yeah read a couple
others when you're out with people
breaking bread put your phone on airplan
mode yeah that's a good one uh poor
people's drinks before yours people
appreciate that so sea my bud sea he did
that to me this weekend and uh I I was I
was wooed he he woed me and I saw a
picture of you and seea today and looks
like you guys are dating So that
obviously works I'm leaning into his
arms uh it definitely worked um
scheduled 30 meetings not one hour
meetings you get through just as much
yeah I I I totally believe that but
here's the thing here's the thing this
is all obvious now so I'm good at saying
like I looked like an idiot back then
like all these ideas might sound like
stupid ideas right now good water stripe
Atlas thing I'm just joking I think good
water you could definitely make that
work yeah I'm I'm the I'm the guy who
looks stupid in the moment but looks
good in five years a cursed
life well number three is to send
postcards to friends so I I'll be on the
lookout for a postcard yeah you had one
that was like um go to this little
website and they have a bunch of unique
gifts and it's like just show up not on
a gift giving occasion but when you go
meet someone just bring one of these for
them like yeah uh you know people
obviously remember it these are sound
just like you know how to win friends
and influence people but it's real and
like especially in Silicon Valley like
the the social like IQ was like so low
that if you did any of these things like
you know you know if somebody's
listening to this in Texas they like
yeah you pour the other person with
water first or you show up with a gift
but like you know I mean I almost sold
my last company because I met someone I
gave them a tiny Buddha
and they remembered me like they made an
offer to buy my business so it it does
work it's one of those things where
you're like of course I should do this
but you don't actually do it and then
you read it and I'm like all right fine
I'll start I'll start sending gifts
that's the perfect way to explain it all
of these are things that you're like
yeah I know I know those those aren't
new and then if you just said okay cool
let's look at this question differently
how many of these do you do regularly
and now all of a sudden instead of
knowing 10 out of 10 you do one out of
10 regularly like that Gap is why I like
that blog post Greg we appreciate you
coming on um uh you're uh you're full of
ideas I you were supposed to be solo
with Sean sorry I crashed your party
today but things change but uh I
appreciate you doing this and coming
with us this is a blast I was smiling
the whole time good that's a win um all
right appreciate that's the
[Music]
pod